what does it mean to
stop arguing with god
it means
to stop
pursuing trying to
find peace and happiness
through experiences
and substances and relationships
and material possessions
every single attempt
at extracting happiness and peace
that way
leads to suffering
which is the catalyst
that we decided to
use as a course correction
mechanism for us
to realign ourselves
with god rather than arguing with
god
the entire argument with god
happens in trying to
[Music]
extract happiness and peace
from experiences substances
relationships material possessions
the entire argument with god
is when
you argue and force
your point of view into
all conversations that you have
you're not relaxed
you're not seeing yourself the way that
god
sees you as bentino massaro
has been saying
see yourself the way that
god sees you
so what is the delta
the difference
between the way that god
sees you and the way that you see
yourself
that entire delta
is based on you
not turning inward
and recognizing the diamond that's
already
around your neck like rumi says
that your very awareness and your very
beingness the very i am-ness the very
i exist is already
worthy and it is already happiness
and peace as has been said for millennia
with satchit ananda existence
consciousness bliss
that turn inward is
the cessation of the arguing with god
as we used this
during our show on intelligent infinity
you see that as you secrete
and enter into existence
that you go with this fractaling process
to hit this breaking point of trying to
seek
and extract happiness and peace
from experiences substances
relationships material possessions and
as is told in the archetypal story of
the parable of the prodigal son
you hit a breaking point and that then
causes you to go
inward which is the process of finding
which is what
yoga or union or mysticism or hypnosis
means is going inward to uniting
with the very fact that you are already
god you
are already awareness you are already
beingness you are already
i am i exist i am
the very creator and all of these other
selves
are me this is all me this is all one
intelligence present
and then once you get that information
then you've
eliminated the delta so the whole delta
happened in this section
here where people are experiencing the
biggest sludge hammers
of suffering the largest catalyst
that's where the delta is the greatest
that's where your argument with god is
the greatest
it's the very lack of humility the very
essence of i
know that i can extract
happiness from this relationship i know
that i can extract happiness from this
material possession
that is all a massive argument
with god and so
you close the gap on
how god sees you versus how you see
yourself
so you become god seeing you you become
god and as you do that it makes you
able to firework to express your
individuated spark of the infinite from
a place of god's serving god
the creation serving the creation rather
than
your person identity serving a
distortion
a lack belief or
a twist or a kink seeking validation
so it's actually quite simple stopping
arguing with god is the turn
inward which has been called
self-inquiry atma vichara
ask yourself the simple question what
is i who
is me what
is me
what is the i
and as you turn inward and investigate
that
you close in on the delta you close in
on the difference
between the way that god
sees you and the way that you see
yourself
you're seeing yourself when you're
feeling
suffering and all these catalysts that
are trying to get you to turn
inward you're seeing yourself in a way
that is a separate
entity in a physical world with other
separate entities
that you're not identified with
whatsoever
and then the flip
like turning on the light switch
is that when you close in on the delta
on the difference between
the way that god sees you you become
god seeing itself
meaning the way that you see
everything is as god as one
intelligence at play with itself you no
longer become
a separate entity that's physical with
other separate physical entities that
you have no affiliation with
but rather you recognize that you are
god
and the other person is also god and
you're interacting
with god
everything is an experience for god
your identity shifts from person to
god interacting with god
and that's the cessation of the argument
with god
and that's also the cessation of
suffering and malevolence
so most simply put stop
arguing with god stop trying to
seek peace and happiness
in substances and experiences and
relationships and material
possessions stop forcing your point of
view into
every conversation practice for two to
five seconds
just
relaxing your perspective using the
breath
and just sinking inward into awareness
and into
beingness into i am i exist
itself surrender that contracted
i need to force my perspective into the
situation
surrender that to god use the breath and
relax
and watch as
your ability to become more equanimous
and peaceful and graceful and loving and
wise
by not needing to insert your
perspective
ends up acting as a catalyst
for the scenario itself to also relax
and become more peaceful
another way to explain this is that
right now
you have this pipe or this channel
the way that god sees you
and your ego your contracted person
identity has
clogged up the pipe
you've gotten to a place where you're
not receiving
the very divinity that you are
that very
endless waterfall
of happiness and peace that you already
are has a bunch of clogs in it
that are all affiliated with your
arguing
with the one divine intelligence
you're arguing with the one defined
divine intelligence creating clogs
in your pipe by arguing
with the one intelligence because you
think as your person identity that you
know
better you don't know better
and so humility is key
the breath is key
relaxing your perspective is key
seeing everything as one intelligence at
play with
itself is key
seeing yourself the way god sees you is
key seeing everything at play with
itself the way that god
sees it is key the difference is
if you think you're a person interacting
with other
separate people in a finite physical
world you're inevitably
arguing now if you see yourself
as god interacting with
god in a beautiful
creation out of endless possibilities
inevitably you will stop
arguing with god and you will align
yourself
more and more with that divine
intelligence that is piping through
channeling through and you will
surrender yourself
as a vessel to that one
divine intelligence
so become aware that the ego
doesn't want to die
the ego wants to perpetuate itself
the ego is our best tool that we
created as a catalyst for us to awaken
because the ego
is like the attractor just like
maya the intoxicative illusion
substances experiences material
possessions relationships
is like an attractor
and so the ego is the very conditioning
that is drawing us out into this very
argument with god
and as we become more aware of
the entire situation and less like
running automatic scripts we unfreeze
our will and choice and sovereignty
and we end up burning transcending
our very conditioning
and that ego dissolves more and more the
very
attractor of maya has less and less
of a intoxicative pull
on us and then we
land more and more as
how god sees us we land more and more as
seeing the
entire cosmic play as
one intelligence at play
with itself
you could say that the very last step
of awakening of enlightenment
is to know yourself as the very
source of
the one intelligence at play
with itself
so stop arguing with god
and prioritize in your very north star
position
the most radical question you can ask
what is i
what is me
what is my true nature
surrender all of your arguing with god
and turn inward to recognize
you are the source of the one
intelligence at play
with itself
thank you
uh
you